what's going on guys so as requested I
decided to do a very different video a
more laid-back video a more casual video
when I showed you guys my mancave tour
quite a bit of people wanted me to
discuss my amiibos because I'm a giant
nerd I grew up with Nintendo games I
loved Nintendo characters and so thus I
have amiibos it started out very small
it was like I'll buy the Mario I'll buy
a starfox and then like a year later I'm
like hi every single one has to be
bought now it's unfortunate and true but
that's how it always starts for us
collectors isn't it so let's get started
with my entire amiibo collection I will
tell you guys where I bought them how I
found some of them are hard to find ones
the whole story behind them let's get
started so I'll start off with one of my
harder to find ones and that is ness I
tracked this guy down on eBay now one of
the things I'm very proud of in regards
to my entire collection is that I have
rarely ever resorted to scalpers and
even if I saw one that was on eBay it
was always for only a couple dollars
more than it would have been in stores
I've never been dumb and bought a very
expensive thing that's one of the things
I'm extremely happy about because my
entire goal with collecting these was to
not resort to scalpers I found nests on
eBay and I was very happy to do so now I
did review the game splatoon I enjoyed
it very much and so thusly I picked up
the inkling boy and inkling girl and
since I'm a completionist I also got the
3 set that included the squid now I got
all of these at retail price I did not
resort to eBay or Amazon or anything
like that all of these I got at the
store I was lucky to find all of them
now as someone who experienced the boom
of Pokemon I had to get Charizard
because it's Charizard he is one of the
coolest Pokemon out there and I also got
him for just about retail price just a
couple dollars more than retail price
which is fine with me when I see people
who are scalping these for like 35 40 50
dollars I'm like what are you doing stop
we're just people we like toys leave us
alone
let us have our fun dark pit was also a
harder one to find but I got him at Best
Buy they did a restock recently and I
was able to pick him up
$12.99 I was extremely happy when I saw
this thing I was like wait a second
that's kind of that start pit whoa and I
just grabbed it it was instantaneous and
some other people were there too I know
what they wanted I know what they were
thinking and I was like no
I'm gonna get dark pit because I know
one of you is going to grab like five of
them I picked up my Bowser jr. editors
arrest for retail price also when they
did a restock on the same day that I
picked up my captain olimar and on the
side note
I love the Pikmin games they're great
games you've never played them before
all of them are really good Sonic was
one that my wife actually picked up for
me now she got this when it was a little
more uncommon it was harder to find him
in stores they've done more restocks
recently and so he's a little bit more
common to find but it was really cool
when she picked this up for me Ganondorf
was an online purchase and just like all
my other ones I've purchased online it
was just a couple dollars more than
retail as I said I'm not going to resort
to more than like $20 I think is where
it starts to get unreasonable for some
of these guys there's a big zelda fan i
have to have the ultimate baddie of this
Zelda universe of course speaking of
Zelda I have tuned link the character
who originated in the Wind Waker Games
and has now become very popular in 3ds
games I picked up dr. Mario at a target
I think it might be a target exclusive
because I haven't seen it anywhere else
but I've seen it in multiple targets
continuing in the world of Zelda in fact
this kind of is seldom chic I picked her
up at Best Buy and now she's a lot
harder to find a lot of these ones that
are more uncommon I actually just got
when they first were released thank
goodness
pac-man now I have an interesting story
with pac-man I actually got this at
Walmart and it was put out on the shelf
about a day early they did it by
accident it was in the middle of the
night it was like 3:00 in the morning
I'm a night owl I grabbed it I actually
did not know that it was a day early I
took it up to the register and of course
as some of you may know if you are
collectors it didn't scan through
because it wasn't its release day and
then I went oh it's not the release day
okay well you know I don't know what to
do so I didn't say anything I didn't say
a thing and the cashier was like well
all these amiibos are like 1296 $12.99
and I was like mmhmm she was like okay
well I'll just put $12.99 there you go I
was like yes pac-man a day early I'm a
little cheap no I love the Metroid games
and I have zero suit samus I actually
have Samus unboxed I'm only showing you
my inbox collection Samus is upstairs I
have yet to get her in a box because I
was stupid when I got her I took her out
of the box because I love Metroid so
much but whatever I have zero suit samus
picked her up at Best Buy as
well as I did shulk who's one of my
favorite new characters in the new smash
game I was really happy to be able to
find this guy just at a store because
for a long time he was very difficult to
find very uncommon even rare almost
Lucario another Pokemon I picked him up
at Toys R Us
now this little son of a bitch was
really hard to find I actually ordered
him online like as soon as he came out
and it arrived at my house in a terrible
just broken package it had been crushed
in the mail I was pissed I sent it back
to Amazon they sent me a replacement
that one was Japanese it had Japanese
characters all over it so finally the
third one that Amazon sent to me was the
correct and nicely packaged one and I
was like for goodness sakes guys come on
and here I have little Matt who I picked
up at Toys R Us now I have some things
to say about little Mack as a character
in the game most unfair character in the
entire new game he's the fastest
character he has a built in final smash
now it's not just that he has a built in
final smash here comes a super nerd rant
by the way so you might want to put on
your goggles because it's going to get
really fucking nerdy in about a second
here it would be fine if his knockout
move was powered up only by him doing
well by him getting a lot of hits in but
it gets powered up when he gets punched
and when he sucks I could beat the shit
out of Little Mac and his basically
final smash move gets powered up and
it's one of those one-hit kill things if
you have like a certain amount of damage
it sucks it's not fair that was my
little Mac rant and I'm done now now I
was very happy to find Marth
at a Best Buy he was just sitting there
and I grabbed him and I was like Mars
this is amazing he's one of the harder
to find guys he was upwards of 50 60
sometimes even $70 on eBay and I found
him for retail price I also got Mega Man
in the middle of a restock that took
place at Best Buy I always loved the
Mega Man games growing up I haven't
played all of them there's tons of Mega
Man games but he's very nostalgic for me
for some reason
and of course you have to have the king
of all video game villains Bowser
himself
Lucina is actually one of my favorite
characters in smash I use her quite
often and I was happy to find her for a
very reasonable price on eBay now these
guys are available exclusively and only
at Game Stop it has robbed game and
watch and duck hunt interesting story
with this as well I initially
pre-ordered it from games.com and it
I've dip my doorstep with Game & Watch
dislodged and just like floating around
inside here I was like really I mean
come on so I took it up to the game stop
by my house and gratefully they had one
and just exchanged it right there so
moving beyond the Super Smash Brothers
universe we have Yoshi's woolly world
which by the way I'm playing right now
and is a ton of fun I'm having a great
time with this game but I picked up the
yarn Yoshi's blue as well as the green
one and the pink one because I'm a man
and you know you got to have a pink yarn
Yoshi it's essential guys come on come
on guys you know it is now you might
want to know who my best character is in
Super Smash for a long time I didn't
have one and even now I don't really
have one where I'm like yep he is
absolutely my best or she's absolutely
my best
I have bests but one of my bests is
without a doubt King Dedede now he
doesn't get a lot of respect because you
know he's King Dedede
he's Kirby's main villain but I love
playing as this guy and if I can get you
smacked with that hammer you're gone
you're done man fucking nerd another guy
I love his I from Fire Emblem this is a
harder one to find I did get him off of
Amazon Donkey Kong's brother Diddy Kong
I also have Donkey Kong upstairs unboxed
I don't have him in box yet but I was
happy to find Diddy Kong in box and I'm
gonna leave him there because I grew up
playing the Donkey Kong Country games
for Super NES as well as Donkey Kong 64
great games and what kind of amiibo
collector would I be if I didn't have
Mario I mean he's probably the most
famous video game character of all time
if you really think about it speaking of
Mario Peach Mario's main love interest
who is constantly trapped and needs to
be saved you know something's gonna
happen
there's gonna be some kind of revolution
in the mario world at some point she's
gonna have to save Mario I guarantee it
there's gonna be super peach world and
Mario is gonna be trapped and Bowser has
him like tortured and stuff and Peach is
gonna have to fly around and float and
stuff it's gonna happen trust me Pikachu
always my favorite Pokemon I know
easy choice he's like the Pokemon is he
he it's kind of a knit I guess but you
know what it's a heat come on it's a he
you know as you know this is a guy this
is a guy someone I'm actually really
good with in Super Smash for whatever
reason is Zelda I can kick a lot of ass
with Zelda I've always
leichter quite a bit here's an
interesting one we have the 30th
anniversary retro Mario classic color
with the old 1980 style very cool amiibo
a little bit hard to find at first now
he's becoming a little more common this
guy however is a lot harder to find and
I'm very happy to have him this is the
modern color of the same amiibo got him
off eBay from Canada actually which is
the same region as us so it doesn't
really matter
great price form - and you know I'm
pretty sure is the same as in the United
States right now I now my OCD is going
to bother me about this forever
and of course you gotta have link link
is essential to any amiibo collector is
linked so that's really all I have to
say now I talked about the fact that all
pokemons are kind of considered it's to
the best of my knowledge I only know
about the original 150 I'm not as
well-versed in today's Pokemon stuff but
like I said Pikachu's a guy in my mind
he always has been
Jigglypuff to me is a girl like I don't
know it just come on - girl greninja is
a really cool character from the new
game I plays him sometimes I'm not that
great he's kind of like a 5 on my scale
from 1 to 10 of how good I am with him
and other characters but I was happy to
pick him up at Toys R Us if I'm gonna
have Mario you kind of have to have his
brother Luigi as well as his dinosaur
Yoshi Yoshi now along with King Dedede
the other guy who's kind of tied for who
I play with the best is Captain Falcon
this guy is the cheesiest motherfucker
on earth I mean seriously everything he
says is like good dog good ah like I
said one of my best is King Dedede and
his archrival is of course Kirby Kirby
is strangely uncommon now he's getting a
lot harder to find on the shelves so if
you see a Kirby snatch him up or suck
him up to you're into that kind of thing
and for those who've never played a
Kirby game
Kirby sucks things into his mouth that
was not a sexual innuendo people are so
dirty
and finally my personal favorite of all
these characters but for some strange
reason not in the Super Smash game but
his game
starfox I've always loved starfox but
I'm not that great with him in the
actual game Super Smash for some reason
but I love his games so awkward cut here
I apologize but the honest truth of the
matter is I was originally going to post
his video back in November and you guys
voted on Twitter for ghost in the shell'
the new movie to be the video that was
released instead of my amiibo collection
and up until now there has not been a
sufficient gap in new movie releases and
new videos I had to do to actually put
this video up so I've actually gotten a
few more since filming this video so
I'll make this quick I did pick up
Mewtwo at a store it was a really great
find as well as the new Falco got him at
Best Buy obviously I got Paula Tina
online she was an Amazon exclusive I
found this at Toys R Us the me brawler
the me gunner and the me sword fighter
these next two I was very happy to find
that of the villager actually in a store
they did a restock and I was able to
obtain him and thank you to my beautiful
wife I obtained the Wii Fit trainer on
eBay somebody put her up for a very good
price and last but not least Oh mega
yarn Yoshi I want to thank the Toys R Us
guy I don't want to say his name just in
case he doesn't want me to who held this
for me behind the counter when a whole
bunch of other scalpers and desperate
Christmas present seeking parents were
looking for this so yeah I apologize for
this terrible edit but it had to be done
so obviously there are some I don't have
I've been collecting for a year now
because wow the games been out for a
year I didn't even bother collecting the
Mario Party 10 amiibos I didn't really
give a shit about them because the game
wasn't really that great so I'm not
insane you know like where I have to
have everything you know I mean it's
just certain ones I like to have ones
for games that I actually enjoy so guys
thank you very much for watching my
amiibo collection video I know some
people requested it and I hope you
enjoyed it thank you very much as always
for watching guys and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes